Normalement,
il y a Boris qui nous a ramené un véhicule.
On va aller voir ça.
Oh Boris, mon gars!
Oh Riadh!
- Franchement, tu es le meilleur.
- Je sais, mec.
Je ne m'attendais pas à ça de ta part!
Tu vas où, là?
- Tu m'ouvres la portière?
- Quelle portière?
Du véhicule.
Monsieur!
Du véhicule?
Je suis en trott, mon gars!
Mais Boris, je déménage.
J'avais complètement zappé que tu déménageais.
Tu peux m'aider?
Lève le menton,
appuie.
On se capte très bientôt.
Je m'occupe de toi. Ne t'inquiète pas.
C'est quoi, cette tête?
Vas-y.
Il m'a laissé.
Ça y est, enfin, c'est le dernier carton.
Je vois enfin le bout du tunnel.
On y est arrivés.
- Akamz?
- Oui?
Tu fais quoi?
Le meuble à pharmacie,
mais c'est bon, j'ai bientôt fini.
- Pourquoi tu as fait ça?
- Ça tient avec deux chevilles.
Akamz, je t'ai demandé
de vider le meuble à pharmacie, pas de le démonter.
Ce n'est pas à moi, ça.
Il est beau, en plus. Tu es sûr de ne pas le garder?
OK, il est beau, mais ce n'est pas à moi.
- Tu veux que ma caution, elle saute?
- Je n'ai pas envie que ta caution, elle saute.
Eh bien, remets-le.
Après, tu viens m'aider à ranger les cartons.
Arrête de démonter tout et n'importe quoi,
s'il te plaît.
- Allô?
- Oui, c'est Boris.
- Tu es en bas?
- Oui, tu peux descendre, c'est bon.
OK, j'arrive.
Tu repars les mains vides?
Tiens.
Je vais descendre.
Tu as intérêt à ne rien démonter.
Là, normalement, Boris,
il va nous trouver une grosse voiture pour…
Alors?
- Boris!
- Alors?
Je t'ai demandé un utilitaire
ou une grosse voiture.
C'est quoi, ça?
Tu montes ou tu ne montes pas?
Non, je ne monte pas.
Un petit tour!
Donne.
Merci. Toi, tu es un bon.
Akamz !
Frère, tu fais quoi?
Pose cette visseuse, tranquille, doucement.
Pose-la, voilà.
Donne la visseuse.
- Non!
- Si, si. Fais-moi un câlin, voilà.
Je ne peux pas m'en empêcher.
Lâche-moi, maintenant.
Qu'est-ce qu'il m'a ramené encore, celui-là?
Non…
Je sais ce que tu vas me dire, c'est pas grand.
Ta carte, elle ne passait pas pour les gros trucs.
- Comment ça, elle ne passait pas?
- T'inquiète, on va prendre les cartons un à un
et après on va prendre le matelas,
on sangle en haut sur le toit.
On va faire une sangle?
Mais qu'est-ce que tu racontes, Boris?
Rends-la, fais-toi rembourser, s'il te plaît.
Mais frère, tu es sérieux ou quoi?
- Rends-la et fais-toi rembourser.
- D'accord.
Akamz,
on a dit quoi sur démonter les meubles?
On a fini les cartons, il faut bien que je m'occupe.
Décale-toi, je vais appeler le conseiller.
Allô?
Ah! Monsieur Belaïche, alors, comment ça se passe?
Arrête!
Vous n'avez pas un plan pour...
Vous n'avez pas un plan
pour louer des utilitaires?
Si, bien sûr, vous pouvez en trouver
dans l'application Check.
Et si vous avez peur d'oublier quelque chose,
n'hésitez pas à consulter votre checklist
ou à m'appeler, si besoin.
Ah ben, ça, ça peut m'aider.
Merci beaucoup.
Pas de souci, je suis là pour ça.
- Au revoir, Monsieur Belaïche.
- Merci.
Alors, mon gars?
Ah, Boris!
Là, tu me fais plaisir. Là, c'est bien.
J'aime bien les plans comme ça.
C'est bon ou c'est pas bon?
Allez, c'est parti! On y va, Boris.
C'est parti!
Ça va être une dinguerie.
Frère, ça va te changer la vie, un ascenseur.
Il n'y a pas d'ascenseur.
Quoi?
C'est au cinquième étage, sans ascenseur.